the head of russia's orthodox church
patriarch kirill has supported putin's
war in ukraine from the start
he described those opposing the invasion
as the forces of evil now this has
angered many ukrainians who say kirill
has given his blessings to putin to kill
his fellow slavs and people of the same
faith
so far russian attacks have damaged as
many as 92 churches and places of
worship in ukraine
there have also been increasing reports
of attacks against the clergy there
russia's war it seems also has a
religious dimension
much of this religious conflict has been
fueled by the russian orthodox church in
moscow and in particular by its head
patriarch kiro
[Music]
long before the start of the invasion
kirill positioned himself and his church
as strong ideological allies of the
kremlin
[Music]
kirill has repeatedly cast russia as a
defender of divine law against the
forces of evil
which he identifies as emanating from
western democracies
carol's proximity to the kremlin goes
hand in hand with putin's commitment to
the church
in 2012 the patriarch described putin's
political project as a miracle of god
over the next few years he became a
staunch supporter of the kremlin's
agenda
in a sermon in march this year carol
rebuked members of his own church who
opposed the war
we will never make peace he said with
those who violate the law of god
for kirill the invasion of ukraine is a
religious crusade aimed at defending
divine law
those who oppose it are therefore
enemies of god
the kremlin and its forces have
effectively been granted a religious
stamp of approval for their actions
many of the victims of the violence
unleashed by the kremlin and blessed by
the church in moscow are kirill's own
faithful
ukraine has almost 12 000 russian
orthodox parishes
many of which now stand in the way of
russian munitions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and for more on this we can speak to our
religious affairs expert martin gatt
good morning martin now we saw in that
report how close the relationship
between vladimir putin and kirill is how
important is the patriarch for the
russian president
i think that the patriarch is actually
very important for the russian president
for one thing because he actually has
suffered uh not only political but
strong ideological proximity and and
backing
uh to many of the positions very
conservative ones that have actually
emanated from the kremlin on the other
hand you have to keep in mind that the
orthodox church
in russia has about something in the
order of 78 to 80 percent of presence
among the russian people so that means
that
all the way from moscow to
the small parishes
parishes i'm sorry the the the patriarch
the patriarch of moscow has actually
enormous penetration in terms of
politics in terms of social work and
obviously in terms of ideology so it's
an excellent promoter of the kremlin's
position
okay and what so what's his motivation
why is kirill so supportive of putin
i think what kirill says in putin what
the orthodox russian orthodox church has
seen in putin for a very long time
is a kin spirit it's somebody who holds
some of the same ideas and wants a
return to a form of you know very
classical conservatism which actually
opposes a lot of the progressive causes
that emanate from the west so kirill
sort of mentions repeatedly a gay uh gay
pride parades
which in some sense is laughable but on
the other hand i mean this is actually
a good example of the imaginary of a
very conservative part of the country
i think it's worth saying that you know
putin is looking also for somebody that
can or has been looking for somebody
that can do that
for him and so in a sense it's a perfect
match
now carol is on the eu's uh sanctions
list why sanction a priest i mean what
effect would this have if if this if he
were to be sanctioned
well it seems to be the case that carol
is also an extraordinarily rich man who
has actually profited enormously from
the proximity uh to the kremlin these
are mostly unconfirmed reports and
things that sort of circulate in in
open source intelligence and and so on
but this means also that girl has
actually some of the profile of
the inner circle of
of putin and some of the other people
that had been hit by uh eu and your
sanctions
dw religious affairs correspondent
martin gak will have to leave it there
thanks so much